[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais que nous partons en voyage on
semble et pour cela je vous demande de
fermer les yeux
imaginez l'été une plage bretonne calme
dans une lumière de fin de journée l'air
est doux vous êtes assis sur la plage
face à la mer est devant vous au loin se
découpent la ligne d'horizon
plus vous l'observez plus elle vous
fascine
je vous invite à partir ensemble au delà
de la ligne d'horizon
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux si vous le
souhaitez cette image reste gravé en moi
depuis l'adolescence souvenir d'un jeune
moniteur de voile fasciné par cette
ligne légèrement courbe qui me
promettait des trésors et le besoin
inexplicable d'aller voir au delà est
devenu une obsession
rien ne me prédisposait si ce n'est un
goût pour la nature les et les grands
espaces mais le jourdain et plus haute
est rien les olé loisirs d'enfance sont
plutôt la pêche la cueillette la chasse
la balade
j'ai 14 ans lors de la première édition
de la route du rhum quand mike birch sur
son petit trimaran jaune h la victoire
pour une poignée de secondes à michel
malinovski alain colas ne reviendra pas
cette course rentre dans la légende pour
sa première édition et ouvre un peu plus
les portes de la popularité à la course
au large
cette même année voit l'amoco cadiz
venir vomir sur nos côtes sa cargaison
pour moi comme pour beaucoup c'est notre
premier choc pétrolier nous sommes
bientôt 4 milliards d'habitants sur la
planète
la wind surf la planche à voile vient
d'arriver des usa et les sensations de
glisse et de liberté sur ce petit engin
sont incroyables sont dingues
on est le roi de la baie on est le roi
du monde on peut toucher l'horizon à
l'école de voile du cap coz je découvre
un écosystème merveilleux des gens
passionnés en tous genres technique
pédagogie performance fiesta je découvre
le vivre ensemble en fait et rapidement
c'est la compétition qui prend aux
tripes sans savoir si c'est un but tout
un moyen d'aller plus loin ou juste mon
ego qui a soif de reconnaissance
mais bon il plus qu'un désir le grand
large
à 17 ans je me décide je veux faire la
mini-transat une course en solitaire sur
des bateaux de 6 mètres 50 qui relie à
l'époque l'angleterre aux antilles alors
je pars de rien j'ai pas de bateau j'ai
pas d'argent pas beaucoup d'expérience
mais j'ai un rêve et aucun doute sur la
réussite de l'opération
je me donne deux ans et je vais
apprendre les mois qui suivent ce qu'il
fait les fondations du du métier de
coureur au large chercher douter
s'accrocher et trouver un bateau une
équipe des amis formidables à sponsors
gagner des courses et revenir la queue
entre les jambes
parce que ça se passe jamais comme prévu
j'ai coulé je fait naufrage une nuit de
dans le gros temps je or ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui un ofni un objet
flottant non identifié
je vous fais pas un dessin panique
angoisse montée des eaux est un truc
improbable je pense comme sauvée en
premier on est samedi soir il est 3
heures du matin et je vois au même
moment ma tribu de copains dans notre
boîte de nuit favorite et je me dis là
non je peux pas mourir ici tout seul
comme quoi ça sert d'avoir des amis même
quand ils sont absents
je serai récupéré par un cargo je
rentrerai à la maison au fond du trou
mais bien décidés à à repartir franchir
mon horizon et on dit souvent que d'un
échec mais une opportunité je vais avoir
la chance a gelé j'ai 19 ans à ce moment
là de me découvrir le monde de la
construction des bateaux de course au
large en composite
alors petite pause technique qu'est ce
qu'un matériau composite
c'est un matériau d'au moins c'est un
assemblage d'au moins deux composants
qui augmente leur propriété individuelle
si vous voulez le béton par exemple
prenez le mettons fini les plus costauds
que les gravillons le ciment ou le sable
chacun de leur côté pour faire des
bateaux de course c'est pas pratique
on apprend à utiliser à l'époque la
fibre de carbone en imprègne ce tissu de
résine et le produit fini sec est un
matériau extrêmement léger est
extrêmement résistant c'est formidable
dans ce petit coin de la baie de
concarneau qu'on surnommera à plus tard
la vallée des fous on y côtoie d'
incroyable énergie et talent moi j'ai
appris énormément nous vivons bateau
dans mon bateau nous buvons bateau nous
mangeons bateau et on construit on teste
on casse on répare sur une deux trois
clubs l'horizon se rapproche je deviens
donc stratifieurs statut qui sonne
beaucoup mieux aux oreilles de mon père
que celui de futur clochard des mères
dont j'étais affublé depuis quelques
temps et puis les courses continuant 85
a lieu le premier tour de l'europe
l'europe de jacques delors
les primes sont en est qu est pas encore
en euros je fais mon erasmus en fait et
lors d'une escale en belgique le destin
encore en au rendez vous j'embarque sur
le bateau d'eric tabarly pour le tour du
monde en équipage
un rêve pour un moussaillon que moi
petite pause
un marin sans eau il est mort dix huit
équipiers sur un bateau de plus de 24
mètres face au gotha de la voile
mondiale
la promiscuité et les odeurs de
chaussettes sales les quarts de nuit le
poids des voiles tout est immense tout
est infini tout est énorme tout ça sur
le plus beau terrain de jeu du monde
l'océan les surfs interminables dans
langrand 2 ou luce
les lumières unis glee semaine passée en
mer dans un autre espace-temps ça y est
je les trouvais le plus beau métier du
monde
lors de la première escale
c'est à cape town en afrique du sud
je découvre un truc l'apartheid
cette situation est figée bloqué
m'explique-t-on n'y a pas de solution ça
sera toujours comme ça moi qui à 21 ans
n'est encore rien vécu quatre ans plus
tard sur cette même course en 89 je suis
embarqué sur le seul bateau soviétique
ayant jamais couru à l'ouest avec à bord
des moldaves des ukrainiens des
géorgiens des russes il ya sept
nationalités en course au milieu de
l'atlantique sud
nous allons vivre ensemble la chute du
mur de berlin un monde s'écroule pour
mes coéquipiers alors que moi du haut de
mes 25 ans bah je le construis tous les
jours pour l'instant cet instant là ça
me samedi sur le cir et moi je pense à
gagner des courses aller plus vite par
d'autres pas d'autres questions
on est à peu près 5 milliards et demi
sur notre jolie planète en ce dimanche
d'avril 1994 où nous gagnons avec jean
le cam la la transat ag2r pour une
poignée de secondes aussi précisément le
jour où nelson mandela est élu président
de la république d'afrique du sud
incroyable coïncidence c'est un souvenir
qui reste en moi toutes les certitudes
peuvent être bouleversé tout ce qu'on
croit gravé dans le marbre pour
l'éternité ne l'est jamais j'ai 36 ans
quand je prends le départ de mon premier
vendée globe
j'arrive au cap horn dans une ultime
manoeuvre je sors dans le cockpit c'est
un peu métro boulot dodo je regarde pas
à l'extérieur
ce tir et cordages tout d'un coup je
sursaute une sirène
je lève les yeux un paquebot près de moi
et je me trouve sous le regard des
dizaines de touristes des caméscopes des
appareils photo et la chine non ça fait
deux mois que j'en bave pour venir voir
ce caillou tout seul et ici c'est lé
manager les cabanes à frites mais
ou est-ce qu'il faudra aller pour être
peinard la course au large moderne et
très paradoxale mélange entre néandertal
et l'humain 2.0 vivent dans une grotte
humide à quatre pattes ou en rampant
manger et dormir pour alimenter les
neurones afin de maîtriser le top de
l'électronique et de l'informatique
moderne
le tout pour imiter la performance du
dauphin ou le vol de l'albatros mais
j'adore pourtant progressivement mon
horizon va commencer à s'obscurcir au
gré des déchets plastiques rencontré en
mer de l'augmentation du trafic maritime
mondial
tu peux un peu l'impression que l'océan
est un grand tapis sur l'eau sous lequel
on cache la poussière le grand large
c'est encore un endroit où on ressent le
besoin de demander la permission
en rentrant et qu'on remercie en
quittant pourquoi est-ce qu'on a oublié
sa à terre chez le grand écart mais
fondation s'effrite bien que je sois un
marin poussé par le vent est attentif à
la consommation d'énergie du bord je
m'aperçois que je me suis jamais
réellement posé la question de mon
impact sur l'environnement la nature la
part dont la planète est un grand bateau
sur lequel l'équipage augmente et les
ressources dans les cales diminue il va
falloir changer de cap avant la
mutinerie
progressivement je me rends compte
pourquoi mon horizon se bouche mais ça
sert à quoi d'aller de plus en plus vite
si c'est pour aller dans le mur
j'ai besoin de retrouver du sens avant
la panne d'essence mais comment faire
par où commencer
pas parce qu'on connaît les matériaux
c'est fantastique matériaux plastiques
composites qui sont partout à terre
comme un maire aujourd'hui ils sont
issus du pétrole alors que la nature
sait faire tenir debout des structures
incroyable on y trouve des méthodes de
collage dingue c'est comme ça qu'avec
mon équipe est partie laventure dans les
biocomposites comme pour le métier de
coureur au large on est partie des
fondations chercher douter s'accrocher
et trouver et on a créé en 2012
chez queiroz notre structure un bureau
d'études et de réalisations danser dans
ce domaine fibres et résines d'origine
végétale mixez broyer triturer votre
cerveau et vous obtenez les plastiques
de demain
recyclable et biodégradable prenez la
bretagne par exemple le lin et le
chanvre ont fait les voiles et les
cordages de milliers de bateaux la
prospérité de tout un territoire
je suis persuadé que demain avec nos
technologies nous saurons les marier
avec les algues qui poussent avec la
colle pardon issus des algues qui
poussent là sur nos côtes
nous serons autonomes en plastique
propre ça c'est un slogan autonome en
plastique propre et l'équipage augmente
toujours son bateau nous sommes 7
milliards et demi et c'est pas fini
alors quoi
on a peur de l'autre on a peur de
l'avenir on a peur de l'inconnu alors
qu'il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'ouvertures est possible alors c'est
comme ça qu'il ya quatre ans on a créé
un fonds de dotation qui s'appelle
explore pour que le progrès social et
économique soit en harmonie avec la
nature
nous rassemblons une communauté d'hommes
et de femmes qu'on a appelé les nouveaux
explorateurs qui ont la même vision que
nous des éclaireurs qui sillonne le
monde pour innover et sensibilisés ils
testent leurs innovations et préparent
leur expédition dans notre base à
concarneau
nous leur mettons à disposition des
espaces et nos compétences dans le
domaine technique et de gestion de
projets ils nous aident à sensibiliser
nos mécènes et leurs collaborateurs qui
viennent s'immerger chez nous pour y
trouver de l'inspiration
les nouveaux explorateurs sont aussi
dans les écoles font pour faire partager
leur aventure leur découverte pour
montrer aux élèves qu avec de la passion
chacun peut inventer son métier marée
basse
puisque le monde et ce village
interconnectés nous allons créer bientôt
la plateforme où j explore un lieu
virtuel des changes de soutien et de
mise en valeur de ces nouveaux
explorateurs à la base explore ou
croiserez par exemple les équipes de
corentin de chatelperron qui explore le
monde de l'innovation frugal comment
répondre aux besoins du plus grand
nombre par des systèmes simples le low
tech contre pied au high tech à
l'atelier vous y verrez l'imprimante 3d
à côté qui fait l'éolienne low cost à
côté des vers de farine qui sont élevées
pour faire les protéines est pas loin du
réchaud à hyper basse consommation c'est
aux boîtes de conserve
vous y croiserez aussi emmanuelle et
ghislain bardout qui sont un peu les
costauds des temps modernes avec leurs
expéditions under the pole killer qui
par leur plongée profonde
particulièrement sous la banquise nous
ramène des moissons scientifiques et des
images incroyables d'un monde qu'on ne
connaît pas alors qu'il est en train de
fondre et vous y croiserez toutes les
autres équipes et les projets une bande
de jeunes et de moins jeunes qui ont
tous les étoiles dans les yeux les mêmes
étoiles qu'on avait à l'époque pour nous
prenait pour des fous dans la vallée
c'est marrant parce qu'ils iront
reproduit le même écosystème que celui
qui a nourri ma jeunesse
mino s'imaginait pas que des centaines
de milliers de personnes viendraient ou
au départ de nos courses
et ben moi je rêve que demain ce soient
ces nouveaux explorateurs qui inspire le
public
par leur passion et par leur
authenticité par leur quête de
connaissances et de solutions pour
construire ce monde de demain où l'homme
et la nature auront toute leur place
pour conclure
qu'est ce que j'ai appris derrière ma
ligne d'horizon que la nature est
toujours plus forte
il faut composer avec elle on n'a pas le
choix on en fait partie
que tout seul on n'est pas grand chose
sans l'intelligence des autres que rien
rien rien n'est jamais figé tout peut
bouger à tout instant mais j'ai appris
aussi que modifiée de l'angle de notre
regard nous fait changer nos actes vous
êtes présent ici au tedx à rennes vous
avez la curiosité vous avez l'envi
ensemble nous avons déjà changé notre
regard
vous êtes déjà des nouveaux explorateurs
alors applaudi c'est vous
[Applaudissements]